هذا وقد على صعيدي اخر في ملف اخر افاد
مصدر تركي رسمي لجزيره ان تركيه اعطت مهله
زمنيه محدده للجانب الامريكي والروسي
لاخراج قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه من منبج
وتل رفعت وعين العرب كوباني وقال المصدر
انقر ابلغت الجانبين الروسي ولا امريكي
انا المهره الزمنيه لن تمدد وان البديل
سيكون عمليه عسكريه ضد القوات الكرديه
وبحسب المصدر فان الجانب الامريكي اقترح
اعاده هيكله قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه دوري
الاكبر للمكونه عربي في ادارته
رفعت عن العرب كوباني
سوريا الديمقراطيه على المنشات النفسيه
قال النظري في المقترحات الامريكيه
وضع شروطا تتعلق بالملف الاخراني مقابله
تنازلات ميدانيه وسياسيه في سوريا وقال
المصدر الى روسيا عارضه رفع الغطاء عن
منطقه الشهباء في ريف حلب وعين العرب
كوباني لتسهيل دخول القوات التركيه اليهما
من القرى ينضم الى مراسل الجزيره المعتز
بالله حسن
ومتمسكه بموقفها هل هناك اي مؤشرات على ان
الجانبين الامريكي والروسي قد ربما يغيران
موقفهما قبل انتهاء المهنه
عبد الصمد المعلومات التي حصلت عليها
الجزيره اليوم من مصدر تركيين رسمي هي
ترسم صوره لما يحدث على طاولتي المفاوضات
التركيه الامريكيه من جهه والتركيه
الروسيه من جهه اخرى فيما يتعلق بموضوع
العمليه العسكريه التركيه خصوصا وان تركيا
لا تتفاوضوا مع قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
وانما هذه المفاوضات هي مع الجانب
الامريكي من جهه والجانب الروسي من جهه
اخرى الامريكيون في موضوع التفاوض كانوا
طرحوا على تركيا بحسب هذا المصدر ان يتم
تغيير اسماء تتحفظ عليها تركيا او ترفضها
تركيا في الاداره العليا لقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه وان يزداد او يتم زياده
المكون العربي في المناطق المذكوره الرفعت
ومنبج وهمم ايضا عين العرب كل هذه المناطق
همم بحيث يكون هناك كما تريد ترك زياده
للمكون ال- همم العربي لكن ااا الامريكان
ايضا تحدثوا عن انهم يمكن ان ينفذوا هذه
المقترحات في حال وافقت همم تركيا همم على
ذلك لكن همم كان هناك طلب امريكي من تركيا
على ما يبدو بان انه يتوافق ايضا الولايات
المتحده ان تساعد تركيا في ما يتعلق
بموضوع همم مواجهه ما سمته همم الميليشيات
الايرانيه همم في همم سوريا في نقطه اخرى
الروس ايضا هم يقولون ان همم بحسب هذا
المصدر انه يمكن ان تساهم تركيا في موضوع
المفاوضات الاوكرانيه بشكل اكبر في مقابل
ان تقوم روسيا
دعم تركيا في شمال سوريا وفي موضوع سوريا
بشكل عام ميدانيا في همم في النقطه الاولى
وهو همم ربما رفع يد روسيا عن منطقه همم
الشباب في ريف حلب وايضا همم هذه المنطقه
كما نعلم فيها دوريات روسيه وبالتالي هذه
الدوريات يعني ان القوات التركيه ستكون
متواجده فيها ومدى وسياسيا ايضا اا من
خلال التاكيد على ان روسيا ستساهم في
مساعي همم دعم المسار السياسي المتمثل في
اعداد خريطه الدستور وتحديد موعد
للانتخابات في سوريا تركيا تنتظر الرد
الامريكي والروسي على طلبها فيما يتعلق في
هذه المهنه المهنه وهي اا قد حددت هذه
الموله كما تقول قبل بدئها في هذه العمليه
العسكريه التي تقول ان كل وحداتها
العسكريه هي جاهزه لها وايضا الوحدات
العسكريه التابعه للمعارضه السوريه في
شمال سوريا هي ايضا على اهبه الاستعداد
لهذه العمليه شكرا لك المعتز الى حسن